hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and
make it fancy let's see what we are
making fancy today
drumroll
instant stuffing as a new match said
i've never tried this before my
expectation is probably too dry
and
not too flavorful but let's try this
almost look like a savory bread pudding
it tastes like instant ramen noodle this
is just hot water butter
and this stuffing mix this is a little
bit tricky but i do have a cool idea as
always i'm excited to
make it fancy
alright here's what i got
parsley
thyme mushrooms prosciutto dried
mushroom dried cranberries heavy cream
chicken stock butter puff pastry onion
rosemary sage garlic celery shallot and
turkey breast from the pantry i got soy
sauce flour eggs and sparkling wine okay
let's get started
make it fancy
thanksgiving edition
so first i'm going to melt 2 tbsp of
butter over medium heat and while it's
melting
i'm going to chop garlic
just crush
minced garlic so butter is
melted add onion so it's a half large
onion
and one stack of cellulite saute until
it's softened chopped rosemary very fine
too
so really what was your introduction to
thanksgiving i think maybe when i moved
to the states i was invited to my
friend's giving taki looks a little
creepy too like it has
the thinking
underneath their chin add a little bit
salt just a pinch so it will cook a
little faster are you surprised when you
saw what black friday was i don't like
crowded place like i feel like if i'm in
that circumstance i get so stressed out
so i'm pretty fast cyber monday okay so
anya and celery is softened so i'm going
to add garlic and you want to add garlic
a little bit later on the cooking
process because garlic tended to burn so
make sure
cook onion and celery first time
time is already like smally so i'm going
to use my fingers
pop them in
adding the rosemary i just chopped it's
about one tablespoon
so onion is softened and translucent so
it is ready i'm adding one box of
stuffing and
toss them well
so this is combined rest in here warm up
one and a half cup of chicken stock four
tablespoons of butter
so chicken stock and butter is reached
to a boil so i'm going to
pour over
[Music]
and start to combine
once it's
kind of soak up all the chicken stock
and butter take off from the heat cover
the lid and steam for about five minutes
what do you think that the stove top
instant stuffing was inventive i feel
like those kind of instant thing was
popular in 70s
so
i would say 1973
1972. oh i was gonna say too so if
you're just using instant stuffing mix
you are just using water and butter but
i'm adding onion and celery
and herbs and cranberries so it has more
texture and flavor it looks like absorb
all the moisture so i'm going to add
chopped parsley
two tablespoons of cranberries it kind
of gives nice
tanginess
okay so this is looking good and it is
colorful and pretty so i'm going to let
it cool let's move on to next step okay
so we have turkey breast i
always feel like turkey is dry
this is only one breast cut them in half
butterfly cup open it up we're gonna use
plastic
i'm going to use
hammer
and make it thinner
pound very thin about quarter inch
season with salt season from high so
you are seasoning evenly and season with
pepper spread cold stuffing evenly
you want to spread and kind of use your
hand
and pat it evenly roll
i think this dish will be perfect for
smaller gasoline
thai with trying so i tied this up and
it feels secure oil is heating in the
pan over medium high heat and i'm going
to sear turkey
golden brown each side about three
minutes each here at the side as well
and you kind of have to lift it up and
sear
nice golden brown all sides transfer to
a sheep and but i need a one more tongue
okay so i'm going to
transfer
it's so heavy
maybe i'm gonna just use the
tongue
me versus turkey oh yeah i'm gonna just
ah
okay so it was me versus turkey i won
and we're gonna move on to next step so
i have prosciutto i have a plastic on
the table and i'm going to lay our
prosciutto a little bit overwrap each
other
the prosciutto is i usually cut very
thin so
try not to break it but even you break
it's okay i love prosciutto i was so
sad when i found out i cannot eat um any
cure to me during pregnancy and i
layered five of them right underneath it
another five prosciutto
just like a little bit overwrap each
other wrap turkey in a prosciutto
blanket don't forget to cut twine
yeah if you forget it you end up eating
this like string no one want that
wrap it up
right now the end is a little bit loose
but don't worry about it we will clean
it up okay so use this plastic
like very tight
we are going to
press against
the surface
as tight as you can
and look like very plump tie on the end
like a candy i'm very proud of my baby
is it cute
this is not cute because it's not round
it's almost cute so i'm going to put
this in the refrigerator to chill about
15 minutes
[Music]
so my meal baby is chill sprinkle flour
on the surface and i'm going to use puff
pastry i think i will need about five
to use water to glue together use your
finger
and dip in the water
and press down with your finger
need a little bit more flour
with a rolling pin
roll this puff pastry a little bit
larger so it look like big enough to
wrap everything
and wrap the egg wash on the end to seal
transfer to the baking sheet
close the end like
wrapping the gift
use egg wash
and seal
to end put this in the fridge about 15
minutes and we have more things to make
so i have another sheet of puff pastry
and i'm going to make decoration
i will need
about five strips half inch each i'm not
good at free handing even like hanging
picture on the wall i always
put something cricket if you don't have
this tool you don't need to use it you
can use a knife you can use bench
scraper you can use pizza cutter
whatever you have i have this nice cute
cookie cutter to look like a leaf and
also use flour
so it doesn't stick
to the puff pastry and press down and i
made this cool looking
leaves for decorations so this has been
chilled in the fridge
use egg wash
brush it all over so the decoration can
stick this will
give you nice shine when you bake
starting with the long strip kind of
alternating each other so
it's like a lattice
and putting down my leaves now
and i'm using egg wash to stick them
to the log put more egg wash on the
decoration i feel like i'm a bob ross of
the cooking decoration is done and i'm
going to top with flaky salt
i'm going to bake this in over 400
fahrenheit about 20 minutes and then i'm
going to reduce the ovens to 350 bake
another one hour this is very heavy
about
one
i have
one cup of chicken stock
i'm going to bring this to a boil i'm
adding one oats of dried protein
mushroom turn off the heat put the lid
on top and steep for 30 minutes we have
some mushrooms
i think this is shimeji mushroom but you
can just use like whatever mushroom you
can find at the store we found this
mushroom medley all the mushroom is
small bite size and i'm going to saute
i'm heating up the pan over medium heat
melting butter
one tablespoon i'm sauteing one shallow
finely chopped drink a little bit of
salt
so once shallow is translucent add a
mushroom and saute
add some salt to season
give a nice toss
all the time
cook the mushroom five to seven minutes
until moisture is evaporated add in a
half cup of sparkling wine and cook for
three to four minutes over high heat
until all the sparkling wine is
evaporated so i think sparkling wine
will add nice adult flavor and it's both
my favorite thing mushroom and sparkling
wine add in one tablespoon of flour cook
for one to two minutes just want to
eliminate those kind of raw flour flavor
and then i strain poaching mushroom
while it's cooking i'm going to chop
this i like poaching mushroom i like any
kind of mushroom i've never met mushroom
i don't like add to this
saute about
two three minutes
this is a reserved mushroom soaking
water it gives nice flavor so i'm going
to add that
half cup of heavy cream adding around
two teaspoon of soy sauce to taste soy
sauce will give some nice umami flavor
to it i'm going to bring it to a boil
simmer until thickened if you don't want
to use alcohol it's totally fine just
use two tablespoons of vinegar for the
grates this is looking good and i'm
ready to move on it's perfectly baked
golden brown
i'm so glad those kind of detail is
still showing pretty leaves and flaky
salt and nice lattice and i have some
left over herbs so i'm going to use this
for decoration just give nice you know
holiday vibes
i'm using two spatula
and
put in the middle
and we are done
[Music]
thanksgiving turkey wellington very
fancy
i'm so excited to give this a try
give some nice gravy
a little chunky i love this
spiral it looks so pretty
[Music]
it's really delicious
cranberries and herbs
improved stuffing a lot prosciutto gives
nice saltiness to the turkey because
taki is a little bit bland flavor and i
think i love this gravy the puff pastry
gives nice like a little bit sweetness
to it crispy on the outside and tender
on the inside
overall i'm so happy how it turned out
thanksgiving dinner in one bite thank
you so much for watching i highly
recommend you to make a home when you
make it please tag me on instagram and
don't forget to dance make it fancy
[Music]
[Music]
you